[Music]
[Music]
hang on there's something wrong with
this scene these shouldn't be here nor
these sprinkle in some of these and
there we are
much better
i think
the nativity is one of the best known
stories of all time but there are some
weird parts to the original tale that
often get overlooked and there are a
bunch of non-christian elements like
gifts trees and mistletoe that were
originally pagan customs so what was the
first christmas actually like and where
do we get all the unusual traditions
gather round grab a warm festive drink
and place a yule log on the fire it's
time to explore the stranger side of
christmas
the christmas story can be found in the
new testament the gospels to be exact
they are four semibiographical accounts
of the life of jesus the story of his
miraculous birth or nativity is only
mentioned in two of them matthew and
luke they roughly share the same
sequence of events but as we shall see
there are some significant differences
between them our festive tale begins
roughly two thousand years ago in the
roman occupied province of judea the
puppet king herod rules the throne in
the small town of nazareth a girl named
mary has just been told that she's
pregnant this is a surprise to her
especially as she's still a virgin
perhaps more surprising is that she's
being told this by an angel the angel
gabriel to be exact when it comes to
biblical history the angel gabriel is
pretty new to the scene prior to this
he's only appeared once in the bible in
the old testament book of daniel here he
acts as an interpreter to the strange
vision the prophet is experiencing in
fact he's more popular outside the bible
appearing in several apocryphal texts
one of which is the book of enoch an
apocalyptic tale about a heavenly war
against a group of fallen angels gabriel
is one of god's lieutenants along with
fellow archangels michael uriel and
surial it seems that by the new
testament gabriel's fighting days are
well and truly behind him nowadays his
job is to deliver news of unexpected
pregnancies to startle teenagers in
matthew's gospel we get to hear joseph's
side of events from his perspective his
betrothed wife has got herself
mysteriously pregnant suspecting an
affair he secretly plans to divorce her
at the last minute however he is visited
by an unnamed angel in a dream it tells
him that she hasn't in fact cheated on
him but instead has been selected to
carry god's baby the baby is to be
called jesus an aramaic name that
literally means god saves
back in luke's gospel the roman governor
has issued a census in order to count
the population and everyone is told to
return to their ancestral home mary and
joseph must make the 80 mil journey from
nazareth to bethlehem the census of
queerness was a real historical event
although it took place in the year 6 ce
that's six years after jesus was
supposed to have been born dating jesus
birth becomes extra confusing when we
find out that the real king herod died
10 years earlier in the year 4 bce
historically speaking the roman census
and the reign of king herod did not
overlap contrary to what it says in the
bible this leaves us with an awkward
question when was jesus actually born
many biblical scholars believe that
luke's gospel probably got the dates
confused and so discreetly moved jesus's
birth date to 4 bce to coincide with the
reign of king herod after an arduous
trek mary and joseph finally arrive in
bethlehem but they need a place to stay
you'll be familiar with this next bit
they are told to lodge in a stable
because there was quote no room in the
inn this however is a mistranslation
looking at the text's original language
koine greek and the word in is often
translated for kataluma in reality this
word actually means guest room as in a
spare room in someone's house this has
led to the idea that the holy couple
were probably staying at the home of a
relative although lacking any sense of
privacy this is supported a bit later in
the text where their dwelling is
described as an oycan the greek word for
house the whole idea that jesus was born
in a stable is a myth it doesn't appear
in the bible in fact some of the
earliest christian thinkers believed
that jesus was born in a cave whichever
it was there may have still been animals
present
in ancient palestinian dwellings it was
customary to keep animals on the bottom
floor of one's home which may explain
the whole being born in a feeding trough
thing
after the baby jesus is born a star
suddenly manifests above bethlehem
although it's likely just a creative
addition by the author many have
attempted to find a scientific
explanation behind this unusual cosmic
phenomenon a popular theory is that the
star of bethlehem could have been a
comet
modern astronomers have calculated that
haley's comet could have been visible
around this time it will take a few
years and although comets travel at
speeds of around 2000 miles an hour from
the earth's surface they appear to be
standing still eerily hovering about in
the night sky just like how the star of
bethlehem was said to have quote stood
over the site of jesus birth
noticing this star or whatever it was
are three wise men from the east despite
the popular song these three are never
referred to as kings instead matthew's
gospel labels them as magi magi is a
persian word that was used to describe
priests in the ancient zoroastrian
religion it's where we get the word
magic and magician from the greek
historian herodotus once described these
magi as sorcerers fluent in alchemy and
esoteric knowledge but above all
astronomy having followed this star the
three men finally arrive in bethlehem
they bring with them gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh now if you've
ever wondered what myrrh is it's an
ointment used to embalm dead people an
ominous gift to be giving to a baby if
you ask me the magi do not appear in
luke's gospel instead visiting the baby
jesus are the shepherds whilst relaxing
on the hills outside bethlehem they are
dazzled by a blinding flash an angel the
bible is quick to point out that they
are absolutely terrified by this sight
the being attempts to calm them down
be not afraid
for today in the town of david the
savior has been born unto you with that
hundreds of other angels appear in the
sky and begin to chant and sing the
shepherds promptly flee the scene in the
desperate search of this miracle child
this event known as the annunciation to
the shepherds has been depicted by
artists throughout history although
using far less distressing imagery than
i have
eight days later the baby is taken to a
synagogue and is circumcised according
to jewish custom believe it or not a
number of churches across medieval
europe have claimed to be in possession
of the
byproduct of this procedure you see
according to christian theology when
jesus ascended into heaven he left no
physical trace on earth except that is
for something that was removed during
his early childhood throughout history
there has been a total of 18 claimants
of the holy prep use as it's known this
includes charlemagne who had received it
as a gift from empress irene of
constantinople the fact that so many
people have come forward claiming
ownership of this bizarre relic tells us
one of two things one that there was
either a lot of material that needed to
be removed or two someone has been sold
something that didn't originally belong
to jesus to finish the nativity story
the gospel of matthew ends on a really
dark note having heard of the so-called
king of the jews has been born in
bethlehem king herod has become paranoid
that this infant will one day overthrow
him he does what any good king would do
and orders a mass slaughter of infant
boys in bethlehem in later christian
tradition these babies are regarded as
the first martyrs depicted here as cute
cherubs fortunately there is no
historical evidence of such an event
taking place so many believe that it's
simply a myth the whole thing was
pointless anyway as the holy family had
already fled to egypt having been warned
by an angel there they spent jesus
childhood in the shadow of the pyramids
only to return once jesus had grown up
into an adult and with that our
christmas story comes to an end
the modern christmas story is a
synthesis between these two gospel
accounts we've seen how both roughly
tell the same story but there are some
events that take place in one gospel and
not in the other as the renaissance came
around certain stock images of christmas
became formalized although as we've seen
some elements like the stable are not
strictly accurate
in fact so many non-biblical elements
have been piled onto the christmas story
on the holiday in general let's have a
look at some of them starting with the
date december 25th
noah in the bible does it say that jesus
was born on the 25th of december in fact
the references to shepherds and sheep
may suggest that the nativity took place
in the spring it will be roughly three
centuries later in 350 ce when the date
was officially set but why the middle of
winter was it simply plucked at random
it's commonly thought that the first
christmas celebrations were timed to
coincide with the roman festival of
saturnalia dedicated to the god of
agriculture saturnalia was the biggest
event in the roman calendar it was
basically one giant party the streets of
the capital were rowdy with scenes of
drinking singing gambling and general
merriment it was also a time of gift
giving particularly of small clay
figurines known as sigillaria smallworks
candles called cere would be lit and
wreaths would decorate villas saturnalia
was a time of role reversal the only
time of the year when slaves could dine
with their masters after a lavish
banquet of roast pork and cooked wine
guests would appoint a lord of misrule
whose job was to pull mischievous pranks
on partygoers saturnalia was typically
held between the 17th and the 23rd of
december and was followed by the day of
the unconquered sun or soul invictus
this day took place on the 25th of
december and it marked the winter
solstice the shortest day of the year
once christianity was adopted as the
official religion of the roman empire
saturnalia waned in popularity and was
eventually replaced with christmas we
don't know much about how these early
christmases were celebrated by all
accounts easter was the big one in the
religious calendar but as you can
already see many events of saturnalia
like gift giving advent candles and
festive dinners were able to survive the
transition as christianity spread
outside the borders of the roman empire
up into the pagan tribes of northern
europe indigenous folk practices soon
became absorbed by christmas germanic
and baltic people were known to decorate
pine trees with nuts berries and small
charms the celts believed that mistletoe
had magical properties and was used as a
fertility symbol druids would hang
mistletoe on doors to ward off witches
and demons as i'm sure you've already
guessed by now these ancient customs
form the basis of many beloved christmas
traditions
for most of its history christmas wasn't
the big holiday it is now it was most
often celebrated in pubs and taverns and
an opportunity for drunken merriment and
mayhem because of this it's been banned
a number of times in 1647 oliver
cromwell outlawed all christmas
festivities believing that they
encouraged immoral behavior
christmas cheer would not return to
england until 1660 when the monarchy was
eventually restored christmas also fell
out to favor in america where it was
seen as too english of a custom it was
not until the 19th century when the
holiday went through a revival authors
like charles dickens sought to bring the
heart back to christmas putting
family-friendly values front and center
their books captured the imagination of
their readers and helped put christmas
back on the calendar where it became the
warm-hearted winter holiday that it is
today
christmas has had a strange two thousand
and something year journey to get here
with many twists and turns along the way
wherever it is celebrated it fuses with
local customs and cuisines in east asian
countries like japan it is customary to
eat fried chicken instead of roast to
turkey in countries in the southern
hemisphere like australia christmas
takes place in the middle of summer and
is often celebrated with a barbecue
perhaps christmas has become so popular
because it's no longer strictly a
religious holiday whilst many do observe
its religious significance many others
like me just enjoy the chance to get
together with family and friends however
you celebrate this period or don't
celebrate it at all i wish you peace and
happiness in whatever you get up to
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one i had good fun
making it if you'd like to see more why
not subscribe a like and a comment also
go a really long way i need to rest up
over the holiday season but we'll return
early in the new year in the meantime
click this playlist here to watch some
of my videos that you may have missed
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye